it has been a while since the last time
that i did one of these this is
basically an unboxing video
where i'm just
very excited you want to watch a grown
adult woman
get way too hyped about an oversized toy
how do i even where to start there are
two boxes
there are two i actually probably bought
this three years ago i don't know what
it even looks like at this point because
it arrived i think a little bit before
the pandemic and i didn't have enough
room because i was living in a studio
apartment which literally like would not
fit these two boxes in there and then
the pandemic happened so they were
sitting at my old office
for over a year and i was like well i'll
just leave them there until i get a
bigger place that was always part of the
plan now i have a bigger place so i'm
gonna unbox this statue that arrived
like a year and a half two years ago and
i'm so excited let me just show you the
boxes
[Applause]
here you go like i said one box two box
that area is being repainted right now
so it looks very weird but um
let's do it
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god this is huge
look at the size of
whatever this is that i don't remember a
lance this is
i think probably gonna be the biggest
stats you wanna own this is probably
going to be bigger
than the batman who laughs that's a very
big
bat cave holy hell look at it
this is a horsetail
[Music]
dude
i'm s
i'm losing my mind
it's bigger than my entire torso
time for box two let's go
[Music]
this is a lot of pieces
this is a lot of pieces okay
oh my gosh she's so big
you've got a crossbow
here what is this
oh it has multiple faces
beautiful
oh this is the one we're using oh my god
[Music]
this is cool this part has like an
actual
leather strap in it
let's see
[Music]
the main is a detached piece oh my god
you guys
this is like one of the top 10 happiest
moments of my entire life
whoa
the horse head
dude
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
i'm freaking out
this is
the coolest thing i've ever seen in my
life and i get to look at it every day
it wasn't so big
holy [ __ ]
good on you old alana where are you
treating yourself oh my [ __ ] god
this is so big
oh this is the
i mean
come on
i feel like crying
holy [ __ ] dude okay
[Music]
this is kind of neat
one of the arms came with um
346 tape on it which means that mine is
the the 346th
uh they left the tape on before they put
it in the box but i kind of like that
okay this is awesome
they tell you how to put it back in the
box i had so much trouble with that with
my uh batman who laughs statue
this is great we love to see this uh but
i'm gonna have to use the book now
because there are definitely pieces i
don't want to screw up i just decided to
swap cameras because uh the camera
battery is running low but i realize
that in the move i don't actually know
which of my various boxes the uh camera
charger is in so
iphone it is for now
i did not realize
these things are stirrups that's so cool
there's a magnet
in almost every single pot
and these are like actual stirrups
[Music]
all right we're up to a point we're up
to a point where it has pictures
so
that's how it looks with with this arm
but then if i have the lance
i actually think the lance looks cooler
i'm gonna go with the lamps that's dope
[Music]
it's done
oh
my god
it's so beautiful i can move this up a
little bit
i guess i'll decide how it looks in the
corner based on how long i want it to be
holy crap
it's just so beautiful i have um a few
spare parts that are things that you'd
swap out depending on like what hand you
wanted to use
um this is an alternate chest plate if
you don't want to use the batman chest
plate but i like having that the batman
in there i love this detail up here
the horse has a bunch of little bat
symbols on it everywhere oh my god this
is so cool
it's gorgeous let me take this off look
at him
holy crap it's so
like
vicious looking like the horse
all of these little like alma details
everywhere
i love that this is all real fabric and
like the stirrups
this is real it's just magnetized the
whole thing was basically put together
with them with magnets it was very easy
to assemble
so yeah there are multiple arms
um
this lance's this is gorgeous
like even though the base of the legs
the paint
but also just the design like top to
bottom
oh
it's the coolest thing i've ever seen
i've literally never seen anything
cooler in my entire life i'm going to
carefully wrap the
remaining pieces and then i will slide
him into the corner
and we'll see how it actually looks
okay handsome
my god
it was actually pretty hard to place uh
because he's so wide
um
like that could very easily just dip
into the staircase i didn't want it to
be too far forward um it's currently
like in line with the stairs in case you
know if you walk down there i don't want
somebody run into it um
but then i didn't want to push it like
flush the hallway back because then you
miss like the coolness of this pose uh
the tail is also basically touching the
wall so
that's kind of the only way he can go
because he's so goddamn beefy
but i love it
look at it
it's amazing